hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to been and end I'm
gonna hopefully get through more than
just two levels but maybe there's gonna
be a two level per episode kind of deal
but I'm gonna hello moonlight sonata'
there's only one appropriate action for
this epic tour King but slow and steady
to the pace of the music is that timed
is that program to be timed to the music
oh I don't think anyone's twerk to
Beethoven ever in their life
there's Beethoven right oh man candy
sausage tasted the sweet meat I think I
want to stay in the light or what or
what's gonna happen huh oh okay that's
what's gonna happen alright let's take
this for serious like let's not be so
hasty about everything that I'm gonna be
doing let's take a careful planned
approach to this so there's no [ __ ]
that happens I wish I could have a
farther out top down view oh this level
is going to be so this level is going to
be the worst oh man how I wish I could
zoom
yes no it's gonna get head and knows
what's going on as the master of
disaster in this area there's a good
thing I'm not actually looking up
because preferably things do not murder
me from the darkness but much like this
is going to what you missed [ __ ] yeah
ooh I know
see how am I supposed to oh wow I am
very lucky wow I did not see that at all
oh okay the skirting disaster though
what is that no god I gotta thank the
reassembly crews for this even though
I'm an undead zombie and probably
already very dead but except for that
fact I thought that time bets you want
hey these guys are sassy these guys are
the sassiest these guys are not having a
good time it is shown how to have a good
time later later much later much later
when AXI and not about to die from
multiple laser blasts to the groin thank
you okay go open please thank you
checkpoint yes this no no no no what is
this okay I'm gonna run as fast as I can
I see nothing over here yes I'll take
the D over here yes I did it I skip
through everything I don't even care if
I know [ __ ] I don't even care if I
missed any meat I'm not gonna miss any
meat going forward from here hop hurdle
you think you can put obstacles in my
way and it's gonna be a problem the
answer is it is not I don't have much
more no exponent not because I need to
dedicate all my brainpower to navigating
and circumventing these why I was on the
box and the box wasn't in the shadow
area you gotta be some kind of prick to
have killed me whoa all right I wasn't
warming up you gotta give me a chance
here
these guys are sassy to no end these
guys are the Satya
hey come on so if all I got to do is
avoid the giant boxes I mean this does
seem like some sort of child's Playhouse
kind of style deal gone on air I'm
wondering if this is all kind of just
Ben's fever dream as he's suffering from
the actual zombie plague and for some
reason the imagines putting up zombie
friend of his in a gameshow because that
makes sense here we go let's do this
[ __ ] now let's see where this
hellhole takes me
let's see where I'm gonna circumnavigate
the globe with all in this ass tree in
front of me [ __ ] okay we're fine oh god
we're not fine we're so not fine yeah
there's a lot of cans here that I I can
only imagine you're gonna get if you die
repeatedly because I'm pretty sure oh
it's scary oh not good oh where am I
gonna where am I going where am I going
we're gonna come from where to go where
to get firewood in fog be cotton-eye Joe
actually can I do don't don't [ __ ] me
that actually is not what I wanted oh it
was a red herring again again with this
[ __ ] you know I gotta imagine the
guy in the spot like navigating the
spotlight it's just the biggest [ __ ]
that ever God it took so long
Oh eat a dick [ __ ] [ __ ] you man I'll
BRB dad I'm not gonna BRB I'm gonna talk
my way through this one because [ __ ]
that those so much [ __ ] it was sick
just took it away from me
I gotta stop going for the goddamn cans
even though I just did that thing that I
said I should stop doing and then I
don't not do it because I'm a fool I'm a
goddamn fool but anyway like I said the
guy running the spotlight is a handsome
devil and a smart person in fact I
believe that he might be the smartest
person ever in existence and handsome
even though I can't see him but
obviously compared to me a simple zombie
he would be the most smartest handsomest
person to ever
ever grace the face of the earth with
his presence
can I don't don't red herring me okay
good good oh god here we go again
nah there's balls [ __ ] anyway not this
[ __ ] also the person running the
laser trap is just plain old douchey but
they're probably just doing their job at
this point soup du Pape shoot the whip
what's coming at me from the down
something hammer above hammerbob hammer
above hammer hammer oh god the hammer
was above but it was too close
this is so difficult
you guys don't under come on I was just
trying to talk and check the time it's
really difficult you guys probably
definitely do understand but that
doesn't mean that I can't complain about
it because I'd like to complain about
things [ __ ] I'd like to complain about
things and I've got nothing better to do
with my time than [ __ ] that's don't take
that out of context even though no no
I'm not gonna say anything about that
that's no just no just no let's not go
there
yup when I'm in a stressful situation I
just end up talking about any random
[ __ ] that comes to mind because I
got nothing else to do oh there's
there's a sward coming soon I know I
know there's a sword oh I forget it's
not a duck I thought it was a duck from
the last time that I encountered it [ __ ]
how that hurt and writing with chromium
chrome dome punk come on get up no time
to quit no time to be a lazy sack of
crap
lazy bag of bones alright intense
intense gain on ok so the next one
coming up is not a duck I thought it was
a duck turned out it was goose
haha that was you that was the one they
come back for me now I'm 2 4 head there
is a hammer somewhere oh god oh god not
again oh why does it never end why does
this [ __ ] never [ __ ] you that gets
smaller did that get smaller much like
many times in my life I've been asked
that very same question
did it get smaller come on now let's not
be ridiculous focus on the matter at
hand yeah [ __ ] come on oh it's hard
oh god it's hard huh the moonlight
sonata' doesn't help because it just
reminds me how depressed I am and the
failure that I'm reliving over and over
again oh man
cuz I know that at any moment this guy
could just be a dick and then pull it
back right as soon as he moves it
forward which he almost did there okay
we're fine oh oh
cheese and crackers I did it and I got a
lot of the meat oh that was
[ __ ] and a half Nellie
whoa Nellie let's do another whoa Nellie
please don't be bag of Asness I don't
have enough oh I do have enough I just
need to unlock that with a hundred all
right this one seems more manageable
maybe that's probably an entire lie and
I'm laser dome oh boy anything back here
of course there is all right nice music
though pretty cool here we go whoa all
right hang on let's try that again
okay it does get him after you die okay
this is business bizarre
not a hundred percent sure what these
little well what the point of these
lasers are seems like they're just
random yeah yep okay whoa got some kind
of retro [ __ ] music going on err not
[ __ ] but it's good like it yes it would
have go to us eventually oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh god I don't
know I've decided to take that at
breakneck speeds okay I'm just gonna
decide well [ __ ] never mind then I'm
gonna decide that I'm not gonna get
through this in one piece so if I lose
anything I'm not going back for it the
crowds happy about something I don't
know about what it's certainly not what
I'm doing here okay fast [ __ ] can i
still move I can just jiggly wiggly
jiggly
[ __ ] hey we're fine we're fine cake
alright we're good we're good we're good
we're just a little slower than before
there's a checkpoint up there which is
good because they know how badly this is
gonna go I didn't get a golden idol
that's okay I'm gonna restart right
there and I'm gonna be a okay here we go
[ __ ] do a little bit in that I mean is
it just did they put a bunch of [ __ ] did
they put it just a bunch of laser cuts
just put it make a funny joke funny joke
[ __ ] my joke was cutter slowly play it
now did they put a bunch of laser
cutters in the hands of some kitty cats
that were playing with them up above
because they're kind of [ __ ] and
random okay continuing on in a less
stupid fashion that's not the market
player way here we go [ __ ] anybody
that can get through this in one piece
we've gotta be amazing or just patient
that's exactly what I'm not [ __ ]
cut - markiplier amazing victory no hi
it's Mark Myers amazing victory I don't
know what the hell that did it made a
very sad noise okay
oh it open the door so if I can stick
this landing which I can't oh [ __ ] I did
oh I did do I get a checkpoint holy [ __ ]
do I get a checkpoint give me a goddamn
checkpoint you [ __ ]
you better this better of reactivated
this checkpoint because holy [ __ ] that
better have stayed that better freakin
stay that was hard as [ __ ] I like kept
all like body parts better it's dated
I'm just screw you I'm skipping this
[ __ ]
ah ah you ain't gonna give me this time
[ __ ] not this time not this time
Oh what is this ass baguette tree what
does this giant douche miss miss miss oh
hey now [ __ ] I can do that I can do that
because it can reassemble over here so
it's not necessary that you get through
those all in one piece I don't even
think the game developers expected it to
happen so tada
hooray oh this this oh never mind I was
gonna say it was easy but then I
remembered that absolutely nothing is
easy in this game because
funky funky funky funky funky funky them
and Pacquiao said funky Yalda [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
it is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I fell it's [ __ ]
far and far I fell down punky oh [ __ ]
you in there [ __ ] hijo
I lost my legs like I'm a head and
that's all the matters I'm gonna roll my
way to victory
ha I'm invulnerable to your lasers you
can't even touch me with your lasers
what a douche what a douche what a
douche or all these [ __ ] and then
betta bag of dicks with sauce no kind of
sauce I don't think I want to know what
kind of sauce that I use on that bags of
dicks don't need some sauce I don't
think I should talk anymore [ __ ] I
almost forgot about that's a gap I did
it I did something and I got all of them
except for that one but I don't care
because I was close enough so that'll do
it for this episode thank you everybody
so much for watching I'll continue this
on soon oh man this is taking a lot out
of me but thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video